welcome pertinent to this video and it's
a 15-minute game and let's see this is
actually really funny because I playing
a person you from india and i have just
cooked myself hmm tremendously hot curry
i am busy d burning burning inside so
please bear with me one need to drink
something and it has those kind of
drinking noises and away your speakers I
need it I really need some some water
okay so we have a VN our game here with
the Bishop c4 sometimes also arises from
the bishops opening to see Bishop c4 and
with 95 I will get the bishops 92 we are
this is also playable sometimes why it
goes for Queen a3 this type of setup but
not it was obviously a perfectly
playable move I am I will take on c4 but
I will wait for a while see what he's
doing he cannot really am exactly that's
just a question if I take on c4 take
here now I'll take on b3 and play d5
that I think this is the chance I should
not let pass getting the bishop pair and
now playing d5 to to do something in the
center yeah i was making this hot curry
in a way to to honor our challenger
before the World Championship match the
Schiano they had actually add hot Madras
curry powder and madras nowadays is of
course chennai whether World
Championship match was played last year
and
this year nods hometown okay so he has
taken on d5 a number of times which hmm
does not try strike me as the most
ambitious choice hmm but wonder however
yeah the Queen where do I put the Queen
he will maybe play rook e1 and a techie
5 what I need is some coordination of
the bishop to see 65 for example would
be nice putting it on the longer he
might also play at four which of course
it opens up the position which you
normally don't do against the bishop a
but at least it gets him some play on
the Kings side if I do i put the queen
I'm actually thinking of just all the
way back to the aid don't really know i
mean if i go to c6 for example rookie
one looks f6 is going to play d4 maybe I
can play look at the eight then has also
f4 yeah maybe this is not ideal but I
wasn't so sure where else to go yeah
what can you do f4 maybe f4 or rupee one
rookie one maybe rookie one I do f6 I
have I presume I don't do f6 let's say
Bishop s6 Bishop e6 okay this I didn't
expect but it's not a bad move of course
may be trying to play Queen g3 and also
making it more difficult for me to
develop masih ada sure i could play c6
but Queen g3s 23 is a bit annoying
okay c6 is not a move I need to blame
what about the rupee a true create green
g3 Bishop f8 come on let's do that
landing some support to e5 and actually
securing the bishop on f8 so that it's
not so easily exchanged curiously enough
the back rank is quite often a good
place for bishops they still have some
influence influence like the bishop on
f8 is going all the way to a three and
they are not easily exchanged because
quite often the bishops and gain their
full strength only later in the game so
sort of tucking them away is so often a
good good strategy so c6 yeah let's do
that Queen g3i while 26 is not a great
more I can play F sex though I can play
of 6 yeah Queen f6 might be a bit
awkward after F for now we're f4 is
actually not a problem maybe deform as
he ate is hanging up yet is hanging
maybe just f6 slightly awkward but I
don't see a big drawback
my idea next would be to go Bishop e6 27
something like that or Bishop e62 f7
okay he's trying to use them they each
pawn
hmm I try that's a bit irritating if he
goes all the way with the H poem I
wonder if 27 could be a moose queen d 72
g form looks a bit unnatural but it's
not necessarily bad now h 5 ER sir not a
happy move for me I mean I cannot play
at five but if he goes h5 it's a bit
irritating for me all the way to age 6
yeah it's not done it's not the end of
the world but it's a bit strange he goes
h5 now and age 6 I probably need to move
the jeep on and it would really loosen
up my my structure quite a bit yeah I
wonder if after age 6 I should play just
g5 it can be can be a very unstable
structure with all kinds of sacrifices
looming maybe what if I go King h8 h 6
and then try to maybe maybe I can
actually take it trying to use the g
file for my own plane maybe like rookie
72 g7 after the capture it does not does
not look right though if I go g5 what is
act what is this move actually I'm
intending to take on age 6
Queen edge too probably otherwise I'll
win the pond yea maybe then this is just
good g5 is there rook takes each five
takes Queen takes King g8 and I don't
see a great move nighty for maybe but I
can take age six now I cannot believe it
now okay so let's do that if I just get
the h6 porn without any severe
punishment and I'm just fine yeah rookie
five but I can take Queen takes King
create and I don't see a continuation 94
it's not a big threat Wow
yeah this is quite similar but I don't
know Knight f6 at the end I don't really
think it should win yeah i played this
really quickly maybe yeah I know we're
looking something very trivial or is
just very confident check it was just
that the distance does not look anything
like anything greater at all for me it
should take sand not sure what what's up
what's wrong with my position you can't
give this check but it's just the check
it's not at all decisive i go to f7 then
he can take the eight Queen takes and I
don't know check I don't think this is
anything anything great of course i can
i can i can overlook stuff this is quite
clear okay Queen takes and this is what
exactly he's got rook and pawn against
two bishops okay question is is there
anything like bad happening quite quite
quickly if not that I'm then I'm
perfectly okay okay he's a ticking on h7
now this is a good move problem
what would help what would be helpful
yellow the Queen trade of the slave if I
get Queens trader done immediately in
very good shape I tell me the moment
that seems seems tricky is it taking on
age seven of course maybe some way but
these got no big threat at the moment
right okay if it takes I'll go quinta
edge aid gaining someone the
coordination mats tricky if it gets too
many pawns for all that it might be a
might be a problem
yes but is this really a threat got this
check here so should I go go into d7
rook check i go to g8 nope no problem
okay maybe you can take now that's
certainly possible take on edge 7 the
check i go to g8 no problem but if it
takes that's rook f3 threatened so i
need to earn watch out for that we
should f5 desrook f3 okay further check
check here look at three check king he
ate this even now now not clear
yeah that's not clear to me I mean I'd
probably just probably worse but it's
not like i'm easily seeing what what's
going on here Bishop d5 had this also
see form but ohc four days look aged
eight trapping the Queen so this is not
really working maybe I should do that c4
okay Jade straps the Queen so he may be
yeah it's all very simple this game is
playing everything instantly
yeah rookie 70 there's a threat
now that's a that's a big problem
rookie 7
I don't see you playing move really I
rookie seven chat I thought King f6 but
he just takes on g7 with a check made
you have can only resigned that where's
this blood bloody black resigns yeah
tough loss from look from a pretty good
position i think around here white is
white assess was really worse but
probably yeah this is just good for
why'd ya Bishop g5 Bishop g5 is just
good for wide yeah I was really relying
on g5 being a move and this means that i
probably have to adjust here here black
just sends two bishops for no particular
compensation but i need to coordinate
them well against his play which I
really failed to do I was only thinking
about for some reason I was only
thinking about this move which is not
really were not really great I thought
computer wants to go Bishop t6e I
thought this was was actually Bishop g5
oh I was overlooking tons of stuff him
okay yeah well look Bishop d6 and when I
saw that move but I thought I could just
take okay and he took their with such a
jew it assesses so basically winning for
white leather front really surprising
but okay it seems that the coordination
is too bad Plex coordination check yeah
24 is just strong
oops check check yeah that's just a
strong rule and this is playing all the
best moves here Andrew ke one wins this
verse was my initial idea but check this
is what I say but i thought okay i
thought the other move was better but
white is so all so much much better here
yeah you played this really well from
from a so on point I mean I mean you
don't watch the channel for political
correctness or being nice to people and
this is just bad what you played it
should be three allowing d5 this is just
a completely enter positional stuff now
opening up the position this is very
good for black even if the computer does
not see it i mean i don't care it's just
giving up two bishops for for nothing
and he didn't really get any concrete
play it's just a matter of the right
setup hmm so i'm pretty sure that this
should be okay
Jeff maybe f6 is too slow yeah maybe a
six was a bit too slow okay well h4
cannot really refute all this what I'm
what I did here would be really weird
yeah Adam here in the ICC software desha
I have stockfish installed because
Houdini keeps crashing then stop which
is giving completely strange evaluation
sometimes it gives some positions that
gave for instance just just to show
after f4 takes takes takes Bishop takes
it gave from this position this position
here as equal but just of course just
just not right I mean I've got those two
which gives black pretty a pretty good
game only the question how much
advantage she has an hour kh4 said
better anyway but yeah I need to do
something else here I mean ok i can go
g6 instead of instead of g5 it was not
what I planned but ok it's it's
certainly playable I feel so bad we had
to allow the the porn all the way to age
6
I'm not sure really what to do and you
can't do something like that and no play
H sixes yourself yeah maybe I should I
and I should do that but yeah what has
gained something maybe this age for move
on this hyhy plan is is really quite
good and the good enough for for being
equal it also could be that Queen d8 was
a bit to be to preserve but I wasn't so
sure what to do here maybe just f6 here
I was a bit irritated because of moves
like d4 and especially f1 but it has a
check of course which I failed to see
which means that F is really a bit of
bit nonsense nonsense d for disrupt the
ages i actually saw and black as in all
our vehicles okay so probably need to go
to see 6am that sets a better move I
guess keeping also an eye on f3 yeah
this is better this is better really and
the this was a bit slow in my in my
setup it's not like totally totally bad
but it serve it fails to address the
important things I wonder is this a move
maybe trying to get over here
hmm i don't i don't really have a great
development here you know this is not
good probably a Quincy sex is really a
bit better I didn't think about the
check the source of the main problem I
thought that here I don't have a grayble
but I have this check apples this um
pretty much instantly is ok for me
computer wants to play this funny move
that strange i'm not sure that i would
have played that but it's not bad it's
gaining a temper yeah we'll need to move
like that so answered by f5 and if you
play the Queen this rook to e8 yeah
that's in fact very nice for black yeah
so I must go to c6 this is really the
way to to punish his his opening play ok
thanks for watching